In is vowel, we want to return true if letters.substring equals a or e or i or
o, so we add those comparisons using or. So, it would look like this. I had to
type letters dot substring a whole bunch of times maybe I should have made that
a variable. And then, every word I used letters.substring i to i plus 1, I
could replace them with letter. That looks a lot better now for is consonant a
letter is a consonant if its not a vowel. So, I can take a shortcut here and
just return not is vowel for the given index. I don't need to tell it that it's
an int. And I didn't actually initialize letter. If I want to test my method, I
can make a new word. I'll fill it with sleep. And now, if I ask if the first
letter is a vowel, I get that it's not because it's an s. If I ask if it's a
consonant, I get true. I would probably want to test a couple more cases if I
was going to ship this code to somebody. But, this looks like it's working for
now.